never compete with someone who has
nothing to lose
be first the master of yourself
the best skill at cards is knowing when
to discard
don't take the wrong side of an argument
just because your opponent has taken the
right side
for the advice in a joke is sometimes
more useful
than the most serious teaching
the great art of giving consists in that
the gift should cost very little and yet
be greatly coveted
so that it may be more highly
appreciated
when desire dies
fear is born
diligence removes impossibilities
there is always time to add a word never
to withdraw one
folly consists not in committing folly
but in being incapable of concealing it
no one must know the extent of his
abilities
lest he be disappointed
rivalry discovers
that courtesy overlooks
the right kind of leisure is better than
the wrong kind of work
[Music]
be open to suggestions
no one is so perfect that they may not
need advice from time to time
things do not pass for what they are
but for what they seem
most things are judged by their jackets
it requires as much caution
to tell the truth
as to conceal it
things have their time
even eminence bows to timeliness
a wise man gets more use from his
enemies than a fool from his friends
friendship multiplies the good of life
and divides the evil
better mad with the rest of the world
than wise alone
the truths that matter most to us
always come have spoken
we have eyelids but not ear lids
for the ears are the portals of learning
and nature wanted to keep them wide open
there is no greater absurdity
than taking everything seriously
cunning grows in deceit at seeing itself
discovered
and tries to deceive with truth itself
without courage
wisdom bears no fruit
there is no wilderness
like a life without friends
to be of use and to know how to show
yourself of use
is to be twice as useful
reputation depends more on what is
hidden than on what is seen
if you can't be good
be careful
never do anything when you are in a
temper
for you will do everything wrong
true knowledge lies in knowing how to
live
he that has satisfied his thirst turns
his back
on the well
dreams will get you nowhere
a good kick in the pants will take you a
long way
things are done quickly enough if done
well
if just quickly done they can be quickly
undone
[Music]
know how to ask
there is nothing more difficult
for some people
nor for others easier
[Music]
great ability develops and reveals
itself increasingly with every new
assignment
[Music]
a person
when he attempts to deceive
tries to please and be supple
never encourage yourself with the word
of the flatterer
because after flattery
a blow will follow
deal with people from whom you can learn
don't choose a wife with whom you can
live
marry the one without which you cannot
live
work is the price which is paid for
reputation
know your unlucky days for they exist
nothing will work out right and
even though you change your game
your bad luck will remain
nothing spoils the first impression
of you
as being late
we accidentally let people take
advantage of us when we forgive their
betrayal
the whole of life should be a process of
deliberation
to choose the right course
reflection and foresight provide the
means of living in anticipation
the best
and best of us depend on others
we have to live either among friends
or among enemies
it is better to sleep on things
beforehand then lie awake about them
afterward
every fool stands convinced
and everyone convinced is a fool
the faultier a person's judgment
the former their convictions
you should therefore never reveal what
causes you pain or pleasure
so that the former may quickly end
and the latter long continue
[Music]
say farewell to luck when winning
it is the way of the gamblers of
reputation
quite as important as a gallant advance
is a well-planned retreat
never have a companion that casts you in
the shade
everyone could have been preeminent at
something
if they had been aware of their best
quality
all men make mistakes
but the wise conceal the blunders they
have made
while fools make them public
two kinds of people are good at
foreseeing danger
those who have learned at their own
expense
and the clever people who learn a great
deal at the expense of others
recognize things when they are at their
best
in their season
and know how to enjoy them then
avoid outshining the master
all superiority is odious
but the superiority of a subject over
his prince
is not only stupid
it is fatal
when you counsel someone you should
appear to be reminding him of something
he had forgotten
not of the light he was unable to see
[Music]
be extraordinary in your excellence
if you like
but be ordinary in your display of it
strive to have friends for life without
friends is like life on a desert island
a beautiful woman should break her
mirror early
the happy are an exception who
innocently enjoy their simple happiness
one should cultivate good habits of
memory
for it is capable of making existence
a paradise or an inferno
[Music]
cautious silence is the refuge of good
sense
[Music]
not all were born into a period worthy
of them
[Music]
life is a warfare against the malice of
others
never open the door to a lesser evil
for other and great ones
invariably slink in after it
the actual can never attain the imagined
for to think perfection is easy but to
embody it is most difficult
harness the imagination sometimes
curbing her sometimes giving her rain
for she is the whole of happiness
she sets right even the
understanding memory is not only unruly
leaving us in the lurch when most needed
but stupid as well
putting its nose into places where it is
not wanted
all life
you should never have begun
but since you did
you should never end
there are rules to luck
not everything is chance for the wise
luck can be helped by skill
nor should we lose heart if something
doesn't please someone
for there'll always be someone else to
do it
never exaggerate
it is a matter of great importance to
forego superlatives
in part to avoid offending the truth
and in part to avoid cheapening your
judgment
keep the extent of your abilities
unknown
the wise man does not allow his
knowledge and abilities to be sounded to
the bottom
if he desires to be honored at all
he allows you to know them but not to
comprehend them
the spanish jesuit philosopher balthazar
was praised by scopenhauer and nichky
and now he will be remembered for his
well-spoken words in our collection of
his quotes
thanks for watching